hey everyone this is kevin from the
chefs website comm and today we are in
round 6 of our coverage of the 2016
seeing fill cup been a great tournament
so far lots of exciting matches if you
were not aware we do have coverage of
every single round if you're watching on
youtube there is a link below to the
website or you can just go to the chess
website comm slash Sinquefield 2016 that
will also get you there but today's
competitors why it's gonna be played by
Wesley so he is currently in second
place in the tournament he leads only
one man and that is his opponent today
playing the black pieces we have taupe
blob playing great tournament so far we
did cover the match in round 5 where he
played a six and a half hour marathon
session and by the end of it you could
tell he was fatigued afterwards he said
he was just mentally drained so he's
gonna be looking to hold on for a good
game here knowing that he spent a lot of
his mental energy in around 5 Wesley so
on the other hand he's looking to win
this and propel himself to the top of
the leaderboard so we will go head and
get started
so starts out with pawn to c4 pawn e5
pawn to g3 Knight f6 Bishop g2 fin koto
on to the king sign upon here d5 after
the capture Knight takes on d5 Knight c3
Knight back here to b6 and then after
Knight to c6 we do see the four Knights
game in the English opening now that's
kind of a different for Knights game
than you're typically used to seeing
this nights usually over here on c6 we
don't see the exchange early on as often
in this particular game but we do see
the four Knights coming out early on in
this English opening castle on the King
side Bishop ear d7 pawn to d3 opening up
for the dark square bishop to get
involved and then castle on the King
side for Topalov so continues with pawn
to IIITs not being super aggressive with
his English opening Bishop e6 both sides
just getting more pieces involved into
the game Bishop here to III
Knight to d5 attacking we do see some
minor pieces exchanged in the stern of
the board and then Queen to a4 so wants
to complete his development what she has
done he'd really like to bring his Queen
to b3
but that pesky bishop here on d5 is
stopping that so queen here to a for a
rook to e8 and so both sides gonna be
looking to do anytime you complete your
development that's usually the first
thing in high-level play then you want
to start to activate your rook so you
either want to get them on semi-open
files like this one where there's no
pawn in front of the rook here on white
side or you want to control completely
open files or if not if you don't have
any of those you could always just put
it behind some ponds that you look to
push so black would like to bring his
rook over here to d8 but right now the
Queen is there so later on we're gonna
see dobla getting his queen involved and
then swinging his rook over and trying
to control the semi open fire for black
but for now we see wesley so play rook
to c1 is expected upon here to a6 and
the night down to d2 and white has tons
of options as far as how he wants to
continue could push forward with pawn
here to d4 could play rook to e1 rook to
d1 makes sense to me as well pawn to h4
pushing on the king said if you really
wanted to or start to move his knight
over to the Queen side the board also
opened up for his LightSquared Bishop to
attack and that's the route that he
chose I think any of them are fine they
would have definitely changed the end of
the game but he chose that night to d2
Bishop takes on d2 King recaptures and
the knight down here to d4 after the
bishopric captures pawn here to d4 and
then Queen to b3 so as we talked about
getting it to the square he wanted to be
before attacking his pawn on a b7 now
there's two ways to really defend
against this we have the obvious way
which is rook to b8 and that's actually
what Topalov chose to do I think he just
didn't want to go into the tank too much
for just mental capacity because I think
Bishop to g5 does the same thing meaning
the Queen can't just take here on b7 cuz
then the bishop could just take this
night here on d2 so this does stop the
attack but all in all it's fairly safe
to just play look here to be 8 so
continues with pawn to e3 and then we
see I'm passant with pawn takes on d3 if
you haven't seen this move before it
does look a little strange but if
someone plays their pawn two moves you
have one opportunity
only if your pawn is right next to it to
capture diagonal like this and that is
exactly what opal I've decided to do now
I think it's maybe not the best move in
this position because once the recapture
here then all of a sudden Wesley so has
two central pawns and black has none now
it does somewhat expose the King here on
the Kings side so taupe block really
needs to start to get an attack on this
King but it's queen is bishop really
only the ones that can attack diagonally
with this King and that's really the
only exposure that he has but he does
need to get in fact because as far as
the in game is concerned Wesley so
definitely has the slight advantage on
board ruk over here to f8 Knight to e4
getting it involved into the action
Queen to d7 so finally completed
development getting that Queen involved
into the action a rook to f3 just
preparing the rook over here to f1 that
double-barrel rook if you are gonna
durable triple barrel with the Queen you
usually want to get your Queen in the
center of those two rooks so it could be
Queen here on f2 rook to d8 we talked
about this earlier getting it in the
center controlling those semi-open files
is exactly what black is gonna be
looking to do on board pawn to d4 just
stopping that attack pawn to c6 rook
over here f1 just getting behind this
rook so we can start to push forward
Queen down here to d5 saying hey all
exchange Queens on board with you if you
want to in my opinion as I look at this
from towplow standpoint he's trying to
draw the game by this point I don't
think he wants to do anything too crazy
I even think that he looks at SOSE
position and likes a little bit better
so he would like it if so just traded
off Queens here and he didn't have to
worry too much so really like this
position I liked his position as well so
he continues to fight bring his Queen
back here to c2 to bluff continues pawn
to g6 pawn g4 rook to e8 just
centralizing a little bit attacking the
squares that seemed to be a little bit
more risk there's now this backward pawn
here on e3 so attacking that instead
pawn to h3 just solidifying the pawn
chain a little bit on the King side a
bishop back here to d8 opening up the
door for this rook to attack benign
the night is being attacked by the Queen
and the rook so something has to give he
decides to play a Knight to c3 and
that's really the best option once this
Knight moves have it were to come here
to d2 the rook and I'll come and take
here on e3 because this rook here is
tied protecting the king he can't move
so have to keep that in mind and you can
see very clearly that rook to f4 would
be disastrous
protecting the square here just because
pawn to g5 is deadly the rook now has to
move and at that point this Knights just
going to fall as a freebie so all in all
so decided to play the best move and
that is Knight to c3 forcing the Queen
to move after the Queen moves now Knight
over here to a4 pawn to b6 is the way he
wants to protect getting preparing for
the night to come to c5 stopping this he
does have different options that we
could have played Queen to d5 because
now if the knight were to come to c5
then we just see exactly we talked about
before the Ruhr coming down here taking
on e3 the rook can't take back because
the Queen is here on d5 so I think
that's probably a little bit more
aggressive how I would have liked the
plate but he's decided to play pawn to
b6 this does stop it but it also ties
his Bishop down to this pawn protecting
it unless later on he wants to try
something else with this pawn formation
I usually don't like to tie my pieces up
later in the game protecting pawns I
like to be a little bit more proactive
in my approach rook over here to c1 just
starting to attack knowing that it's
probably a little more difficult on the
Kings side here since to love done a
good job of getting all his pieces over
here protecting the Kings side so so is
gonna start to attack on the Queen side
pawn here to c5 we do see an exchange
and before we see some some recapture
and we first see pawn to b5 forcing the
knight to move I think that's exactly
the way to go Knight back here to c3
Queen here to c6 Queen here to d2 and
then we see an interesting move of rook
to e5 I think you just have to take here
on c5
I see no reason not to after queen takes
on c5 Knight comes up here d5 Queen back
here to e7 I think this looks completely
fine I see nothing wrong with that it's
tough to give up material you saw he
gave up that material here on c5 and not
give anything back in exchange he
doesn't have all his materials back here
on the 8th ring so he doesn't have some
big attack that he's looking to do he
just plays his rook down here to e5
trying to protect this pawn but he could
just take the pawn if you wanted to so I
thought it was a little strange to play
rook down here to e5 now when the work
comes to e5 we see pawn to b4 just
solidifying the pawn chain pretty much
saying I don't know what's going on
because now I just have a free pawn
which is really really weird
a bishop down here a g5 rook to d1 and
then the bishop takes on e3
unfortunately though this pawn is not
free and this is actually a big mistake
I'm not sure if you really calculate it
but after the Bishop to e3 Queen up here
to d7 is it's pretty deadly because of
this past pawn here on c5 if the Queen
takes then the pawn just gonna start
pushing up that's definitely gonna be
bad after the rook takes on at d7
obviously the Queen comes back here to a
trying to hold on but Knight to d5 just
getting ready for the night to actually
come here to b6 so it can protect the
square here on a c8 unfortunately for
black his Bishop is not on the light
square where it's the promoted pawn
would be here on c8 so that's another
negative is we kind of like a taupe loss
position Bishop back here to g5 pawn to
c6 pushing forward and then Bishop back
here to h4 one of those moves where you
know I just think he's really getting
tired cuz h4 just doesn't make a lot of
sense either
I could have instead played rook down
here e to check and then maybe King g1
queen c8 queen takes rook recaptures
recover here to c3 that's fine but he
decided to play Bishop to h4 now rook to
d2 and I think he probably should just
pushed here I'm not sure if he was a
little
scared about the rook eventually coming
down here to e2 but it could have played
pawn to c7 and been completely fine now
if rook to e2 we could see king g1 rook
c2 trying to maybe attack there but then
rook to f1 over here starting to put too
much pressure on this f7 square black
would eventually fall in this position
but after Bishop here h4 I will see rook
to d2 and then rook down here to e1 and
if I didn't think Bishop to h4 was a
good move I definitely don't think rook
down here to eat one is he's potentially
trying to get behind enemy lines with
rook here to see one but it's just too
late rook to c2 stops any of that
nonsense King to g7 not doing much at
all either night to b6 is pretty deadly
attacking the Queen forcing it to move
also preparing for the push pawn here to
c7 it has the Queen and the rook
protecting it and then the night's gonna
be protecting it on this c8 square Queen
to d8 and then
Queen down here to d4 check and in this
position Topal AAB decided to resign now
as always we'll start to look at some of
the continuations we could say what if
pawn to f6 tries to stop that attack
while in that position just pawn to c7
and then this is just gonna be all bad
the Queen can't come here to c8 as we've
already seen the knight would just take
it once the Queen moves the pawn can
just come up here the knight could
capture the rooks protecting it that's
all bad news so that's one option that's
gonna be completely bad if we were to
see Queen to e5 potentially in that
position the Queen takes here on e5
after the rook takes then the pawn up
here to c7 there's no way to stop the
promotion without losing significant
material so all in all toe Bluffs
although the writing on the wall and
decided to go ahead and resign so Wesley
so congratulations to him excellent
excellent match moves up into first
place toe blob drops to second place for
a tie hopefully he can get some rest and
come back ready to go in at
next round because he made quite a few
mistakes in this game was definitely not
at the top of his game has he has been
for most of the tournament a few moves
at the end of round five but all in all
he's played a great tournament so hope
you guys enjoyed round 6 been a great
tournament so far again make sure you've
checked out all of the other rounds if
you haven't already and I will see you
in round 7 thanks for watching